there is an interesting uh history
behind Taxi Driver it's one of those
things that's fallen down into Hollywood
Legend I have no idea if it's true
Scorsese had made Taxi Driver Marty said
I'm having a big problem I just want to
show you the shootout at the end and the
MPAA slapped it with an X they said what
they're telling me we're going to get an
X rating I've got to cut the scene and
the legend goes that Scorsese stayed up
all night drinking getting drunk with a
loading gun and so Marty was actually
plotting murder at that point and could
he get away with it in the morning he
was going to shoot the executive at
Columbia for making him cut his
Masterpiece and some of his fellow
filmmakers and friends came and tried to
talk him out of it but here's what it
turned out you had a great idea the idea
that came to him was just to desaturate
the color and the final shootouts
he dissaturated the color turning what
was candy apple blood red into a more
burgundy blood and the MPAA gave him NR
rating yeah